to engage the youth you have to connect
with them and that's exactly what a
Catholic priest in Poland is trying to
do using hip-hop music to spread the
holy word Jacob Bartok raps about
chapters in the Bible going to heaven
and fighting the temptations of the
devil I want to invite people to the
faith or simply to ask about God's often
young people are very busy looking for
some value in their life to have no time
maybe even have no such opportunity I
would like to remind them that the first
step can be taken my music is not
something far-reaching but he is
mobilizing people to take the first step
such as a question or showing away
forward a road that leads to somewhere
when he's not carrying out his community
duties his making music videos
determined to prove priests have similar
interests to everyone else as a result
he's made those in the church more
approachable gaining the respect of his
superiors as well as those in the
industry nowadays is very hard to admit
to faith but rap has always been for
courageous people no matter what they
must always have the courage to talk
about it whether it be about religion or
about living in the blocks there is no
place for weak people in rap music
he's yet to achieve a nationwide number
one but his music is a hit among many in
his community a new album is now in the
pipeline naturally there's a religious
message this one reads Jesus is waiting
let's go Danny Vita Nova CH Sky News